I was confused with throwing the ball
it's a ball right the thing that you
throw it
squirtle yes colonel I know names now I
can name drop who I met scrotum crabby
I killed a couple of those Wow crap
another crap I just caught this crab is
it a different crab all I know about
Pokemon go is I haven't heard anything
else since last week everyone instagrams
have Pokemon in them now I know it's a
thing and I feel like a grumpy old man
get out of the way I don't know I don't
get it it doesn't look fun it's people
walk like they're still laughing there's
no running I guess I want to know what
everyone's hyped about obviously I need
to know which one's Pokemon the nerds
are gonna hate me oh oh okay Steve I had
no clue all right you gotta look for him
see the area so you go move them around
to look for
gotcha the crabby was caught whatever
that means at the beginning I was really
self-conscious and then you just kind of
look around and notice everyone else is
doing it so you don't look as weird as
he'd feel like you do I was expecting
like a little dopamine rush every single
time the first time was great it was
exhilarating
not an ideal throw but snagged him and
he's locked in there
boom but then after that oh no just kind
of Teeter off a little bit I didn't care
I'm just gonna sit here and let the [ __ ]
you walk around and then like there's
these pokey things right cuz they're all
I learned today they're all pokey mines
you find them and you throw balls
I got hip points whatever that means
stand out its head president it was
confusing like I thought I had it and
then the gap would shut off on me and
then thought I had it but I was on a
different menu at one point I found one
but it was sitting on top of a stranger
and I felt really weird like quietly
going up on dirt and trying to throw
pokeballs at her I hated having my head
down I like watching people I like
looking at things like I'm in the park
it's a nice day and then Here I am just
going like this
the best part was that now when I hear
everyone talking about it I'm gonna know
exactly what they're talking about I got
it on the first try I'm way better than
I was five minutes ago I'm not addicted
I'm not addicted and when they say they
spend hours doing it I'll know exactly
how crazy they are best part was really
seeing randoms like turning in circles
like I was a pain loss I don't get it
really I really don't get it I don't
know what I'm doing I think it is a very
cool idea if you're gonna play something
you might as well be walking around as
long as you're watching where you're
going I'm just dropping it into there's
a bomb I caught you two you're both
[ __ ] Birds